12 mètres de long 2 100 km d'autonomie
et des allures de tramway la mobilité
s'offrent une nouveauté plus écologique
dans les yvelines 100% électrique ce bus
pourra transporter une centaine de
voyageurs
les premiers et parmi eux le maire de
versailles sont plutôt qu'on dit et il a
tous les aspects d'un wagon de travaux
et des fenêtres qui sont plus basses
donc une visibilité parfaite pour
l'extérieur
le tramway c'était très séduisant je
dirais ya dix ans mais aujourd'hui la
vraie modernité c'est d'avoir les
avantages du tramway avec les avantages
du bus et là on en a la démonstration
est donc on est très contents de servir
de lieu de démonstration un lieu de
démonstration qui s'étend de vélizy à
versailles sur la ligne 23 du réseau
fébus conçu par alstom ce bus nommé à
petit ce est une concrétisation de la
région ile-de-france en faveur des
transports
c'est la région qui à travers
ile-de-france mobilité qui a investi
dans ce premier prototype puisque pour
l'instant c'est qu'un prototype on a la
chance de l'avoir pendant un an
en test grandeur nature c'est un
investissement de 600 mille euros équipé
d'une dizaine de packs batteries le bus
et recharger tous les soirs son
originalité ses quatre roues directrices
à l'avant et à l'arrière
elle change la conduite par rapport à un
bus classique mana ori analyse sa prise
en main pour former les futurs
conducteurs
il va avoir un gros temps d'adaptation
aux conducteurs pour le prendre en main
parce qu'on n'a pas du tout la même le
même positionnement sur la chaussée dû
au fait que les roues sont sunu le
cockpit conducteur est légèrement décalé
vers le milieu du coup on se positionne
pas de la même manière sur ligne droite
si le test est concluant les premières
livraisons de ce modèle auront lieu en